[Music]
if you want to participate in our
society fully you got to get vaccinated
for workers
and customers in indoor dining in indoor
fitness facilities
indoor entertainment facilities this is
going to be a requirement
the only way to patronize these
establishments
indoors will be if you're vaccinated at
least one dose
okay there you got the mayor of new york
city announcing new rules for the big
apple mandating proof of vaccine
vaccination via coven to enter
restaurants gyms
theaters you name it anything indoors so
i decided to hit the street to find out
how this mandate will
impact the city that's already
struggling from the impact of the
pandemic take a look
[Music]
so you represent over 4 000 restaurants
mayor just came out with this guidance
what does it mean for you
yeah you know listen our city's
restaurants have been absolutely
devastated
and this is another imposition that's
going to be extraordinarily tough for
restaurants to deal with restaurant
workers have been put in the impossible
position throughout the pandemic to
essentially be the covid police
honestly i'm not real happy about it i
think that it's
my business whether or not i wanted to
be vaccinated
and i don't feel comfortable telling
that information to just anybody
i don't think it's necessary at this
point you take precautions
you wear the mask if you feel that like
you need to and you make yourself
comfortable i don't think
it's important that we show it do you
feel comfortable
sharing your vaccination status
i don't even know i haven't really
thought about it
but it sounds fishy though i mean
honestly why not right if you're
vaccinated and you have your card with
you or some proof why not i don't really
see a downside to it if you're not
vaccinated you can always stay outside
i feel like it's a good thing and i'll
feel safer
and i think more people will come to new
york as a result what about the people
that can't
get vaccinated they may have like
medical issues or
national immunity how do you feel about
that well
i would think that they will have to get
some kind of permit or something like
showing that right because it wouldn't
be fair we speak with restaurant tours
throughout the city
and there's a lot of people with a lot
of different and passionate views about
this
but the one thing that we know is we
can't get shut down again
and if that's a potential threat we need
to do everything now to avoid it
thanks for going out there laurence good
job pleasure let's bring in a fox
contributor and law professor at george
washington university jonathan turley
good morning to you
good morning good morning what how does
this play out will this hold up in court
it probably will because the standard
that applies is relatively low of a
rational basis
courts have been highly deferential to
states in fact a state mandate of this
kind in massachusetts
was upheld in the early 1900s there was
also a lower court decision
involving mandated measles shots in new
york that was
upheld but it can be challenged we've
seen a challenge by a law professor
recently
who has natural antibodies and is
challenging
george mason university which is
requiring him against the advice of his
doctors
to get vaccinated anyway so we're going
to look at the details on this so-called
new york pass
but the key here is that many of these
proposals have been supported by people
who say we really have to make life hard
on the unvaccinated a cnn medical
analyst said that recently we have to
make it as difficult as possible
to live without the vaccine so there's
this type of coerced
consent model that is kicking in here i
was reading
last night on this channel sean hannity
was talking about
how apparently in new york city only
about 33 percent of
african americans have gotten the shots
that means two-thirds of
african-americans in new york would be
barred from going indoors to restaurants
and shops and
gyms and stuff like that that's right
and and this is going to have a
disproportionate impact on that
population
it also leaves us contradiction of other
activities that
are not prescribed in this way two
professors recently came out and said
that going out in public should now be
viewed as a privilege
not a right and they analogized it to
driving
where you have to get a license and
that's how far this rhetoric
is going you know they're ignoring the
fact that being on public
impacts other rights the religious uh
observation free speech right of
association
but they want to use the sort of driving
model that if you're not
vaccinate if you're not vaccinated then
you're sort of like an unlicensed driver
who i presume has to stay in your house
yeah professor i just got to get your
reaction real quickly does that scare
you
uh because you're a civil libertarian
you're you you
have great defense of the constitution
so with these laws being implemented in
the country and it seems like
a lot of society is accepting it is that
a chilling effect
it it does lawrence it concerns me a
great deal that's why we don't
we have driver's licenses but not
licenses for free speech
you know the the united states
government and state governments occupy
that space
that we don't occupy they don't indulge
us we indulge
them they're there to structure the
rights that we
enjoy and that narrative seems to be
flipping with some of these academics
interesting stuff let's see what happens
uh jonathan thank you very much for
joining us
thanks professor thank you thank you